since design week we wanted to put our
design skills to the test in a little
something we're calling design derby
but gosh i would love a worthy adversary
who's as design obsessed as me
i'm so lucky i know of someone it is
comedian actor author woman
extraordinaire host of the circle on
netflix and design darling and our dear
friend michelle butch
and of course we have the best host to
take us through it all it's rossi ross
matthews that's right
this is a very serious game and here's
how it's going to go down ladies i'm
going to ask you a series of design
related questions you'll each write your
answer on your little whiteboard right
there and whoever gets the most right
wins a prize for their half of the
audience hey
which half am i which half is michelle
all right drew you're playing for that
half of the audience over there
and michelle this is your half of the
audience right here you're playing today
okay
what are we winning i'm so excited i'll
tell you at the end okay oh god there's
stakes there are stakes all right let's
go question number one take a look at
this this is an arco floor lamp oh yeah
it became popular when it appeared in
the 1971 sean connery film diamonds are
forever it has a very heavy marble base
how much does this lamp cost
oh
write it down on your board whoever gets
closest without going over gets the
point like price is right style why am i
nervous why don't you reveal it because
you have a whole group of people
counting on me i don't want to let you
down
all right okay let's take a look at how
much you think that arco floor lamp is i
mean it depends where you get it from
but i'm going to say around here
3 200 to 3 300 okay
all right good guess drew
2 500 okay
the uh actual price for that arco lamp
is
three thousand six hundred ninety five
dollars michelle
yes michelle got that right which means
this side of the audience you have one
point
i'm so proud of us all right question
number two
is a drawing challenge oh no yeah you're
gonna draw you have 20 seconds to draw
the famous eems lounge chair
this is an iconic chair that popped up
in tv shows like frasier
house and every gay in palm springs has
it
but the drive not j i didn't go to art
school who's got the best version this
is not good a drawing challenge okay and
time is up time is up reveal drew reveal
yours
well done actually uh michelle let's
take a look at yours i mean you know
well let's see how how close they got
this is what the actual eems chair looks
like
yeah
okay
so you know what i actually think you
both get a point because you both did
really well
okay oprah you get a point you get a
point okay my team is mad
my team is mad i see hands up there not
liking it shopping
listen everyone calm down the game is
two for michelle one for drew but anyone
can still win this let's go to question
number one all right oh gosh all right a
hugely popular furniture and design
store uh gives all their furniture
swedish inspired names we know them
right their feel about shelves are go to
if you're going for a rustic
a rustic vibe how do you spell
feel about
it's swedish
more like bachelor vibe that has to use
his mom's credit card but that's okay
[Laughter]
[Music]
i don't know oh god i'm oh god i'm glad
i didn't get the photo okay drew hold
yours up ooh feel about
okay that is a really phonetical guest
um
okay uh michelle what is your spell okay
i got very nervous so it's not no not
this
but this
i don't know why you have um laos uh you
know yes those are those two little dots
i will say there are umos in the real
spelling it
feel about is spelled
uh f j a oh um l-l-b-o
which means neither one of you were
close really no wait isn't there a j you
said there's a j
michelle gets this one you want to give
her a point yeah i should have gotten
the chair but she thank you
you guys we got another boy
all right guys so much all right okay
drew this is it you're gonna you're
gonna win on this one okay question
number four it's a picture scramble look
behind you oh who is this popular
interior designer who was once a regular
guest on the oprah winfrey show
he's also appeared on this show
turn around
nate berkus yes nate berkus love him
did i get that one you get that one
you'll get that one i'm playing for that
side right there
final question
is worth three points so it's anybody's
game okay
all right this is a physical challenge
no i didn't stretch next to you is a
pile of rug samples when i say go i want
you to
flip through and find the rug that best
resembles chevron print okay come in
three
two
one go
there is no gosh darn chevron in here
where's the chef
that's a hat
which means the winner of the drew
barrymore show design derby
it's all in my face
michelle you are a worthy adversary in
that plaid suit you are giving it well
thank you so much and guess what your
audience is getting it because they're
winning a price but you know what you're
all gonna go home with a prize
it's a 100 gift card to costa farms you
can freshen up your living space with
some plants did you know plants relieve
stress that is science and you're all
getting a 100 gift card get some plants
thank you costa farms for that
[Music]